today's morning rounds health experts
are urging the estimated 45 million
Americans who wear contact lenses not
need to change their habits the CDC says
sleeping in contacts can increase the
risk of an eye infection by six to eight
times about one third of contact lens
wearers say they sleep or nap in their
contacts dr. Christopher Starr is an
opthamologist at Wilde Cornell Medical
Center good morning dr. Starr good
morning why is it so dangerous to sleep
in your contacts well the risk of
infection is very real when you sleep in
your contact lenses oxygen permeation
goes down bacteria like sort of damp
dark places with no oxygen and no
movement when you're blinking during the
day you're cleaning your contact lenses
throughout the day and when you sleep
and you're not blinking there's bacteria
you can just grow and infect the cornea
and it can be very serious
you can't Sherman am either you can't
swim in them either water is bad pond
water pool water shower water so take
out your contact lenses before you swim
and in the morning take a shower and
then put your contact lenses in but
beyond you should take them out
you really should yeah you know I know
people do it but it's recommended to
never sleep in your contact lenses and
the way you dispose of them to also
makes a dick about this so daily
disposable contact lenses are great
they're probably safer you don't have to
worry about solutions and cleaning and
all this that being said people 45
million people wear contact lenses a
third of those wear daily disposables
and 25% of those throw them out in the
toilet or in the sink yeah and so that
actually adds about 10 tons of plastic
into the water supply each year and that
plastic I just toss it in the toilet
yeah I used to do that too I don't think
yeah yeah it's Madhu it as well I'm
guilty as charged
but now I would never do it again and
the reason is because all that plastic
ends up in our food it's a pollutant to
the environment but also to to us
because it gets into our food so the
what to do is you throw them in the
garbage or in a recycling bin there yes
it's plastic so you can throw it in
there are some actual programs for
recycling actual contact lenses as well
so clearly you have to be responsible
with your contacts yes thanks the
question what
age in contacts so majors yeah actually
10 years old is a good starting point
for kids who are mature and who will not
make a lot of the mistakes that we're
talking about do you know any mature 10
year old I have one and mature enough to
wear contacts probably she doesn't need
up yet Halloween's coming up next month
I can't believe I'm saying that but it
is but but a lot of people wear colored
contact lenses
one of their costumes it's late yeah
colored contact costume contact lenses
first of all are illegal in the United
States so if you see them on a shelf
they should be reported quite frankly
their leaves do not put those in your
eye those cause the risk of infection
goes up 16 fold with those Casas no
costume contact lenses they're terrible
do not put them in your eyes good they
freak me out yeah plant a different
costume a fairy when you open the door
and there's somebody there in a moment